Країни півдня Європи, для економік яких життєво важливі доходи від туризму,
поступово відкриваються для туристів попри пандемію.
Кіпр, Греція, Мальта, Італія Португалія остаточно визначаються з тим,
як уможливити наплив відпочивальників без ризику нових спалахів коронавірусу.
То куди і за яких умов українці вже на початку літа можуть поїхати покупатися і позасмагати?
Нині в Туреччині діє жорсткий загальнодержавний локдаун.
Місцевим заборонено виходити з дому - лише за продуктами і з перепустками на роботу.
А от іноземним туристам, зокрема й з України - дозволено, практично, все.
На туристів не поширюється комендантська година.
Вони можуть вільно гуляти майже порожніми вулицями та без тісняви
оглядати туристичні пам’ятки. Приміром, собор Святої Софії.
Це традиційно найбільш відвідувана принада Стамбула.
Але нині тут немає натовпу відвідувачів,
тож туристи можуть спокійно фотографуватися.
Це цікавий час для огляду різних пам'яток - порожні вулиці,
порожні туристичні принади. Це справді гарний час для туристів у Стамбулі.
У нас не так багато можливостей зараз для подорожей з України.
Туреччина - одна з небагатьох країн, які відкриті для нас.
Тому ми вирішили приїхати сюди приблизно після року сидіння вдома.
Локдаун - це чудовий час, щоб подивитися Стамбул.
Саме спокійний Стамбул, бо я бувала тут раніше, коли він був багатолюдним,
коли тут були натовпи туристів.
Поки туристи насолоджуються, багато місцевих жителів вкрай обурені.
Вони мусять дотримуватися комендантської години ще щонайменше до 17 травня.
Це несправедливо! Мої діти запитують:
"Чому туристам можна бути на вулиці, а нас заточили вдома?"
Туристи знають, що ми - країна з високим ризиком зараження.
Я не проти, щоб вони приїжджали, але вони ж знають про ситуацію з коронавірусом тут.
Нам загрожують неабиякі штрафи, якщо ми залишимо свої домівки, а туристи можуть вільно гуляти.
Це нечесно. Але ми з цим нічого не можемо вдіяти.
Туреччина нині має один з найвищих показників зараження коронавірусом у Європі.
У квітні доходило до 60 тисяч випадків на день.
Тож багато людей тут підтримують суворий локдаун, але не розуміють, чому
це не стосується туристів. Уряд же, схоже, готовий на все, щоб Туреччина
не залишилася без туристів, бо економіка країни вкрай потребує
успішного старту літнього сезону. Представники галузі, як-от продавці
сувенірів біля собору Святої Софії, підтримують таку стратегію.
Пандемія зруйнувала туристичну індустрію.
Але поки ще є деякі відвідувачі, є і надія.
Зараз їх лише декілька, але ми раді кожному.
Стамбул може прийняти багато гостей. 90 відсотків можливостей міста нині не використовуються.
Продавці сувенірами, такі як Еркан, сподіваються, що торгівля
біля Софії з приходом літа пожвавиться, і вони зможуть прогодувати свої родини.
Сусідній острів Кіпр - теж одна з улюблених цілей українців - з 10 травня вийшов
з часткового, вже третього за ліком локдауна.
Скасовано дію системи офіційного дозволу на вихід людей з дому за допомогою текстових повідомлень.
Знову запрацювали магазини не першорядної важливості.
Але нічна комендантська година з 23:00 збережеться.
Також острів починає приймати вакцинованих туристів без жодних обмежень на в’їзд.
У міністерстві туризму зазначають, що з 10 травня мандрівники,
які пройшли щеплення від "ковіду", можуть приїхати на Кіпр
без жодних тестів і карантинів.
З України теж уже можна потрапити на кіпрські пляжі.
Кіпрська влада перевела Україну із "сірої" у "червону" зону,
що дозволяє в’їзд за певних умов. А саме: це наявність негативного результату ПЛР-тесту,
взятого не пізніше, ніж за 72 години до вильоту,
а також ще один тест вже після прибуття на Кіпр.
Готуються приймати іноземних гостей і греки. В країні вже відкрилися пляжі.
Парасольки і лежаки, згідно з приписами, розташовані на відстані
не менше чотирьох метрів, регулярно проводиться дезінфекція,
а також перевіряються співробітники пляжних барів та інший персонал на COVID-19.
Цього тижня у Греції запрацюють також ресторани та музеї.
Українських туристів- у межах відкриття кордонів для низки країн з-поза Шенгенської зони -
планують приймати з 14 травня. Головна умова - негативний ПЛР-тест
або сертифікат про вакцинацію, затверджений українською владою.
Умови потенційного в’їзду українців та інших туристів на європейські моря
у більшості країн півдня ЄС схожі. Передусім це негативний тест на коронавірус
перед відльотом, а іноді й після прильоту, або вибіркове тестування на COVID-19
в аеропортах з огляду на актуальну ситуацію із захворюваністю в тій чи іншій країні.
Також деякі країни розглядають можливість заміни ПЛР-тесту на
експрес-тест на антиген, щоб зменшити туристам витрати на подорож.
Але насамперед, щоб українці знову могли користуватися перевагами безвізового режиму,
від української влади чекають офіційні зразки сертифікатів вакцинації,
які можна буде належним чином перевіряти на кордонах.
МОЗ України анонсувало, що збирається запровадити COVID-сертифікати з 1 липня.
Потім їх ще треба буде інтегрувати із відповідними сертифікатами ЄС.
Тож, цей процес може затягтися, особливо з огляду на те,
що в Україні дуже поширений бізнес з підробки результатів тестів,
і належної довіри до українських документів поки немає.